with Deadpool 3 X-Men 97 Agatha darkle
Diaries and many more MCU projects
coming up soon the MCU is getting really
exciting once again but apparently
Marvel Studios has a ton of plans in
store for this year's San Diego ComicCon
sdcc Hall h According to some insiders
Marvel Studios was supposed to already
have announced some pretty big things
however it's looking like Marvel Studios
really is taking time to focus on really
making good quality movies and shows and
just making good decisions in general
you all of course have heard about this
and Marvel Studios has pushed a lot of
things back in order to make sure the
quality is good unfortunately it seems
like when they pushed the movies and the
shows back they also kind of pushed back
their agenda for their announcements
however on the opposite side the great
news is it looks like San Diego
Comic-Con this year is going to be
action-packed with announcements so
let's dive into what they could talk
about from the X-Men to the recasting of
Jonathan majors and more and if you're
new and you love Marvel be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos we're also giving
away a PS5 and Xbox series X more on
that at the end of the video so to start
it off although there have been reports
that stated the Fantastic forecast might
be announced by the end of this week
that was according to John campia he
said that last week but it now looks
like that is yet another thing they are
waiting for Sand Diego Comic-Con for now
if you haven't heard Pedro Pascal just
got confirmed to really be Reed Richards
and it looks like Marvel Studios is
really doing everything they can to be
the ones who officially announced the
Fantastic forecast today you might have
seen online because everybody was
talking about it the SAG SAG Foundation
website confirmed that Pedro Pascal
would be joining the MCU yesterday Pedro
Pascal attended the SAG after Foundation
career retrospective in LA and in
Pedro's bio description on the SAG
website not only did it say that he is
joining the MCU you but it stated that
he was going to begin production on the
film The Fantastic 4 soon but here's the
funny thing about that apparently they
got the call from Marvel Studios and
that is no longer listed on their
website so if you have looked online and
noticed that the Fantastic 4 is trending
that is why because of this big reveal
however people have recently noted that
it has been taken down even after people
have been linking this all day and have
already seen it but basically what this
means is Marvel Studios wants everything
to be in their own hands of course we
understand that and according to Alex
Perez Insider from the cosmic circus
when asked about why it's taking so long
to announce the Fantastic forecast
officially he said this idealistically
speaking if you were Kevin feige in
Marvel and you wanted to officially
confirm the cast that will play Marvel's
first family for the next decade or so
wouldn't you want a grand spectacle and
Stage the size of the letter H so
according to Alex Perez Hall h is when
we are going to get a grand spectacle
for the announc ment of the Fantastic 4
which makes perfect sense especially if
you consider Marvel Studios did not
attend Hall h last year and we all
remember
2019 the ending of San Diego Comic-Con
where Kevin fige said we didn't even
have time to talk about mutants or the
Fantastic 4 well it looks like 2024 5
years later is when that is happening
it's actually crazy to think that that
was that long ago but it really was it
was 2019 sdcc well it looks like he has
time now in 2024 and speaking of the
mutants it seems like Marvel Studios
might have changed their plans a little
bit for the X-Men and it's a good thing
based off of everything that we've heard
over the past few years it sounds like
Marvel Studios was originally planning
on waiting until after phase six after
the Multiverse Saga was over to really
introduce the New Mutants and new X-Men
team in the MCU however plans might have
changed because of Jonathan Majors so
obviously at this point in time we all
know that King was really supposed to be
very involved in Phase five in phase six
throughout different projects a lot but
of course since jonath the Major's trial
where he was found guilty and they let
him go he is no longer playing King the
Conqueror plans have changed and based
off of what insiders have heard it
sounds like Marvel is indeed going to
recast Kang and not simply get rid of
him altogether but they are going to
kind of sweep him under the rug for a
bit meaning Kang isn't really going to
show up anywhere soon he might be
mentioned here and there but really he's
not going to be nearly as prominent as
he was before everything happened with
Jonathan Majors so what insiders have
been hearing that we have reported on
several times on the channel is that
Marvel Studios is going to reveal some
new X-Men characters some New Mutants
sooner rather than later meaning they
could come in phase six in fact deadline
reported in September of last year about
5 months ago that their sources told
them that Marvel is going to start
setting writer meetings later this fall
again this was stated September of 2023
but they would start setting meetings
with writers later this fall for pitches
on its anticipated X-Men movie they also
said that it's more than likely that
writer decisions will be made at the top
of 2024 which is right now plenty of
time before sdcc forbes.com even
reported about this as well with the
headline Marvel Studios begins early
stages of X-Men franchise reboot that
was October 3rd of 2023 and based off of
what we've heard from a report from
theed direct.com and from other outlets
as well the movie that would be the
X-Men movie could be called the mutants
of course that is not officially
confirmed at this time so take that with
a grain of salt but it's clear Marvel
Studios has plans for the X-Men in phase
six and to be clear new X-Men not the
original ones from the fox franchise
because we know they'll be in Deadpool 3
and Secret Wars as well so that is
happening because of the Jonathan major
recast and speaking of the recast that
is something that might be announced at
sdcc Justin coll from deadline reported
on January 5th I see a lot of who will
play King next and and here is a top
Contender for Kang comments this week
and I'll say this don't expect that news
anytime soon there will be plenty of
Marvel breaks in coming weeks on various
fronts but don't hold your breath on
that one now these plenty of Marvel
breaks in coming weeks on various fronts
are the announcements that I mentioned
in the beginning of the video that have
probably been pushed back don't get me
wrong we'll still probably get some
pretty cool announcements between now
and sdcc especially since Marvel Studios
is attending Cinema con and we're going
to get the Deadpool 3 teaser trailer Etc
but the big news probably isn't coming
till Marvel Hall h now he said Don't
expect the Kang recast news anytime soon
well that was stated in January and sdcc
is in July the end of July so that is
plenty of time that is definitely not
soon so that could certainly happen at
sdcc and I know a lot of people are
really really waiting to see who they
recast as king or to see what happens
with Jonathan Majors if he appeals and
the decision is reversed and he is found
innocent will Marvel Studios rehire him
we have no idea at this point in time
but hopefully we'll get some answers at
sdcc and of course last but certainly
not least the complete reveal of Phase 6
what's kind of a bummer right now is it
really looks like everything that Marvel
Studios had planned has been pushed back
to at least 2028 meaning we'll probably
get Avengers Secret Wars in 2028 4 years
from now unfortunately we had the
strikes and we had all of the push backs
and now of course with Jonathan major
being fired it pushed a lot of things
back but that shouldn't stop Marvel
Studios from revealing their plans they
usually let us know what they have
planned years out and they already
revealed Phase 6 in part plus not to
mention they've switched a lot of things
up so we have no idea what the current
release schedule is for the rest of
phase five and Phase 6 Deadpool was
supposed to be in phase six but is now
in Phase five it's actually before a lot
of projects that were supposed to come
before it like Captain America Brave New
World the Thunderbolts Etc so we are
fully expecting a phase six update with
most of it being revealed I State most
of it because I think Marvel Studios is
still making some final decisions on
what they would like to include in it so
they're going to leave room to be able
to add things but hopefully we get
announcements for these reported
projects like Doctor Strange 3 the
Scarlet Witch solo film maybe a special
presentation for the Silver Surfer or
Nova so a lot to look forward to and
many insiders seem to think that Hall h
is where everything is really going to
go down for Marvel Studios this year and
really not just this year but over the
past few years this is probably going to
be the biggest event in a very very long
time so let me know how excited you are
for Hall h in the comments down below
and what would you like to hear
announced by Marvel Studios don't forget
to like this video And subscribe to the
channel so you don't miss out on any of
the latest Marvel news and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series X
some Marvel Legends items and some DC
items the winner picks one item and we
pick one winner at the end of each month
you can find us on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof